à amputer à toucy arabes ont joué avec
kaka le public vous jouez également un
week end à rome a gagné et vous allez
mener l'enquêté avec nous et vont donner
chacun leur alibi
on va voir où il est et je vous donnerai
des indices si on va essayer de trouver
qui est le coupable
thierry moreau il porte le poids de 6 kg
je vous dis tout de suite on vous ment
pas il a reposé un moment donc voilà
toutefois de scudo dionne donc tirer mon
grâce à ça sa force est multiplié par 15
oui là thierry tue sans aucun effort
c'est bon signe quand même avec deux
enceintes du ve alors comment on fait
quelque chose de beaucoup plus puisque
on va essayer grâce à cet exosquelette
de voir son prix fracassés cette plante
d'accord bâbord toi tu essayes donc moi
je vais essayer de laisser dans
provalliance je vais pas les essais mais
on va voir si lui l'a fracassé en deux
minutes normalement il a vocation
non mais là pas bon tenez bien la
planche avec comme ça te casser la
planche parce qu'ils nous ont posé bien
tenez moi cette page
[Applaudissements]
on nous amène notre planche il ya là une
2e planche seul un paparazzi sur les
deux tableaux avaler tout et on est
double messenger en apportant une
fraîcheur plan là non essayons avec
celle là comme ça jacasse panne alors
voulait prendre s à l'aller eater faux
mais c'est facile mais il est obligé de
casser avec l'arpa sur nacre à l'envers
non non c'est pas sûr du tout non
[Applaudissements]
ce que la cuisine ça sert on essaye de
voir les films sont tout s'est tu peux
éliminer cet album date est on les aide
[Applaudissements]